hi everyone good day it's a pleasure to
be here thanks Deanna for that
introduction I'm not a national hero you
have to play soccer and do it well to be
a national hero so but it's really a
pleasure to be here as the ANA was
saying a Marc O'Leary basically started
Stanford almost exactly 11 years ago it
was in March and I was attending class a
finance class taught by Jack McDonald
who's still teaching and I had used my
silver bullet I don't know if you still
have silver bullets or not but I had
used my silver bullet to to attend his
classes and he had one day it was before
Google and Google Images so one I always
came to class and study in the first row
I didn't study that much well at
Stanford but I really enjoyed coming to
class and and to lectures and meeting
the people that came to present and one
day I came in early and a guy was
sitting there and and I didn't recognize
him and he said hello I'm Joe doe and
just rest up like Warren Buffett today I
obviously didn't understand the joke so
I said haha i sat alone in a class with
Warren Buffett for five minutes I didn't
say a word to him and the guy actually
was Warren Buffett so so uh so after
that I decided that I had to use jag
McDonald's contacts and I was preparing
my my my business plan for Mercado Libre
which was an idea I had you know
basically having lunch and dinners with
friends here at school and and I'd asked
him to introduce me to to someone he
thought might be interested in investing
in in a project like mine and he said
you know he never says who's coming to
class partly to make sure that everybody
attends to every class and and he said
you know don't say this to anyone but
John Muse was one of the founders of
Hicks Muse will be coming to class in a
month and and I will tell him about your
project during lunch and and I will set
it up so you can drive him to the
airport after after the class
so he did and during the trip actually
before the trip two of my classmates
stepped into the into a car they already
had like ten job offers I I didn't have
anyone because I wasn't looking for a
job I knew what I wanted to do but they
were the type of you know ferns that
they like to be near well-known people
etc and they monopolize the conversation
during the trip and I was I was getting
really nervous I we were going down 101
and he had a private plane so it wasn't
a problem if he if he was there late and
so kind of halfway through the through
the trip he asked me so what are you
going to do after you graduate and then
I started with my pitch with that which
I had I had rehearsed like a hundred
times but I didn't I I knew I wouldn't
have the time to deliver all of it so so
I had to take that the wrong accident
took him to the commercial airport first
and pretending that I didn't know he had
a private plane this was also before
9/11 so after that we were able you know
we went to the private Airport and in
those days you work you went with the
car to the to the plane and he stepped
off the car which was parked right right
next to the plane and took his luggage
and walked up into the plane and I was
standing there with my two friends and
he left the luggage and he walked all
the way down and he told me next to my
ear you know your stories fantastic
fantastic and I'm fascinated by it and I
want to invest and obviously my two
friends didn't quite hear what happened
and they were extremely anxious but I
was still so angry at them that I would
I refused to tell them and I had already
bought tickets to go to Europe with my
girlfriend after after graduation so I
got home I told my girlfriend I'm sorry
but the trip has been canceled we ended
up going to Europe six years later but
but that's how my Collier started and
it's a true story and it happened here
in March of 1999 so with that the idea
today is to give you a brief overview of
Mercado Libre and
make this very interactive so feel free
to interrupt with questions as we go
along and afterwards if you don't the
presentation will be over in less than
probably 2025 minutes maximum and then
we'll anyhow have a time for Q&A so the
origins of Marco lead as I mentioned
they started in in June of 1999 we this
trip was in March of 1999 we started the
company in June and we launched in
August as an online auction services in
Argentina but we quickly expanded
regionally we then did two rounds of
financing we did a first round of
financing in October of 99 where John
Muir's invest Hicks Muse invested it was
around four seven point six million
dollars and they were joined with Chase
capital at the time and then we did a
second round of financing in May of 2004
forty six and a half million dollars
which was led by Goldman Sachs and and
obviously the first round investors also
participated and we had a few other
investors like GE Capital so we during
1999 and 2000 basically we expanded
regionally hired a great team many many
classmates from Stanford leading each
one of our different subsidiaries in
2001 we partnered with eBay they had
acquired a European company that had a
subsidiary in Brazil that compete that
was a competitor of ours and in exchange
for almost 20 percent of Mercalli day
they gave us that subsidiary and we
signed a five-year strategic partnership
and non-competition agreement in 2002 we
bought a Brazilian competitor called lo
cow which was a strong local competitor
in Brazil in 2003 four years after
launch we really started to see some
growth in the business before that it
was all financing
and marketing and I'm focusing on
product but not really that much
attraction in the business so that's a
big change from what you see today
companies like Groupon that went from
nothing to rumors say three billion
dollars in revenues this year in two
three years obviously it's a much bigger
Internet and many of the bottlenecks
that existed eleven years ago have been
solved
like payments for example in 2004 we
launched our payments platform and we
launched a specific business model for
classifieds in 2005 we broke even and we
acquired that remedy which was a
regional competitor that was launched
right when we launched by a group of
Harvard MBAs so that was a huge battle
that's also something that I always
enjoyed telling two Stanford grads
specifically when they asked me to call
admits that have been admitted to both
schools I tell them the story it works
quite well but it was it's a fascinating
story because it was they were all
Harvard MBAs and we were all Stanford
MBAs and we were competing in all of
Latin America and we built a great
company and they got acquired by us in
2005 for 12 million dollars were bought
half of the operation and then in 2008
we bought the other half for 50 million
and today Mark O'Leary's valued almost
at three billion so Stanford is better
than Harvard so in 2007 we IPO we did a
three hundred and thirty three million
dollars IPO which was a huge event
because there weren't any tech IPOs
those days and the day that we priced
was the first time since 9/11 that the
European Central Bank the Fed and the
Japanese central bank together had to
intervene to provide liquidity to the
markets because it was when the subprime
crisis was already at full speed and
there was a huge financial mess which
lasted obviously for several more months
but
and we were quite unlucky however the
IPO was very successful
unfortunately we priced at 18 that day
and the stock closed at 28 we left a lot
of money on the table there and then
it's it's been going up since then in
2008 we also acquired classifieds player
called - karo
that is very strong in Venezuela and
Colombia and more recently in 2009 we
launched two new business businesses
called mercado clics and mercado shops
as you can see we were very original
with our names let me talk briefly about
Latin America it's a it's a very
interesting region the one that we
operate in it has a very good
combination of actual GDP population
size and expected growth we have almost
600 million people in the region with a
GDP per capita of close to $9,000 and
total GDP of close to five trillion
dollars in terms of Internet we are
seeing very strong growth but
importantly we believe we will continue
to see very strong growth going forward
because in relative terms the internet
penetration and the broadband broadband
penetration is still quite low in the
region oops sorry
which is the pointer yeah as you can see
internet penetration is still quite low
and broadband penetration is still quite
low but it's growing very fast so we
believe during the next 10 years we will
continue to see very very strong growth
on our business and in our industry
so this is the projection for for
e-commerce growth obviously in relative
terms Latin America is still quite small
but growing very fast relative to the
other regions in the in the world and we
can we believe this is going to continue
being the case Mercalli basically covers
all of the region it's most important
and largest markets and the objective is
to cover all all the region as we as our
focus is mainly Latin America we are the
largest e-commerce site in the region
and we are the largest e-commerce site
in every one of the countries where we
operate as well
we are the 11th largest retail site in
the world so the law is according to
comScore the largest is eBay second
Amazon in terms of unique visitors very
close to eBay Amazon then Apple Alibaba
that's a Chinese side and we are the
11th largest in the world in Latin
America where the first where 3 times
larger than the second and similarly in
Brazil we are the first e-commerce site
and and this is the case you know
vassilis is our largest market is the
largest marketing in the region as well
and we are the leaders there and we're
the leaders in every single country were
where we operate as well we're also one
of the top internet just destinations in
the region where the eighth largest
destination in terms of unique visitors
so Microsoft is first Google Facebook
and we are eighth and embrace video we
are the ninth so we're also an important
destination there and we basically the
way we have implemented our business we
have four ecosystems what we're trying
to create is a very powerful echo system
made up of four smaller ecosystems that
feed each other the largest business is
our marketplace business and I will
review
each one of these briefly then we have
our payments business and now we're
advertising on webstore businesses our
marketplace business is basically the
eBay or Amazon type of marketplace it's
interesting because we started being an
auction site of used stuff and today 96%
of what is sold on our platform is new
it's a fixed price and 75% is new stuff
so we have evolved the model quite a bit
much closer to the Amazon Marketplace
having said that we're also very strong
in c2c combined the Amazon Marketplace
with Craigslist we're very very strong
in in c2c as well that 25% that is not
new is used stuff sold by individuals
where we are also leaders there and
that's a very attractive business to be
in the c2c business we will see that the
volution of the figure so let me show
you we started this is prior to 2002 we
were embarrassed to show the the metrics
but you can see very strong growth since
last year we we recently announced our
yearly results last year we had 39
million transactions
that's compounding an annual growth rate
of 52 percent during the eight years I
think this is this is close to 20 times
what we were in in 2002 last year we had
15 million buyers and sellers actively
using our our marketplace and that's a
figure that to me is very important we
had four million people selling on our
platform and we had 52,000 people that
make a living selling on our platform so
that's something that for me is I'm very
proud of typically when I go to one of
our subsidiaries I go and visit several
of our sellers and recently I've been
very surprised by the size and the
professionalism that these sellers have
the recently I was in Brasilia with a
seller that has 160
please and what they solely sell on on
our platform so so we are already
enabling very large businesses you have
a question we improved our hour so the
question is why why is there such a big
jump in in in paid listings in the last
year we have paid listings and we have
three listings because more recently we
introduced the ability for sellers to
list something completely for free
without any any sort of fees and it has
been a great move it was risky at first
because we didn't know how much it would
cannibalize our our own business and it
turned out that we grew obviously we
grew listings a lot but we also grew
revenues a lot because what we are doing
is we are convincing sellers to list for
free initially to try the platform but
then to upgrade to paid listings so so
it has worked very well and it we also
improved our product quite a bit in 2009
and 2010 and that enabled listing on our
platform a much easier than what we used
to do in the past in terms of gross
merchandise volume which is a value of
the stuff sold on our platform we grew
from 55 million in 2002 to 3.4 billion
last year this is like 60 60 X or 67%
compounded annual growth rate so those
are some some metrics that are
interesting obviously the businesses
continues to grow very fast and as I was
saying before we believe because of the
characteristics of our industry will
continue to grow very fast for many
years and that's one of the reasons why
we introduced free listings because
there are millions of new users coming
onto the Internet in Latin America these
years which is not what you find in for
example in more mature markets like the
States where everyone has already been
using the internet for a while
not in America you have millions of
people that are accessing the internet
for the first time so so we didn't want
to have any barrier between these people
and our platform so we're happy to have
them list for free and then the free
listings have less traffic so then if we
see that those listings don't convert we
mail them and tell them you hey why
don't you try upgrading to a to a
listing that has more visibility our
second business model our second ago
system is our payments platform that
operates very much like PayPal it used
to be a closed platform that only was
useful inside mercado libre and it had
an escrow component and the buyers had
to pay for the service because of the
escrow service we we've transformed that
in our largest markets Brazil Mexico and
Argentina - a PayPal type of model where
it's free for the buyers to use and and
it's growing very very rapidly both
inside our platform and outside of our
platform in the past with the old
version that we still have in our
smaller markets you could you cannot use
our payment system outside of our
platform so we believe this is this is
going to be a business that has a
potential to be bigger and we believe
this business will be bigger than
mercury and we're seeing very very rapid
growth there and so it's it's a very
competitive business as well we have
local competitors and regional
competitors here these are some metrics
for Mercado Pago you can see a very big
jump in the in the number of
transactions processed and the total
payment volume in the last two years as
we transformed our business model and we
improved our product there's also a big
jump in the adoption with the percentage
of listings within mercado libre that
offer Mercado power a big change that we
did is we used to be like PayPal that's
optional for the for the sellers to
accept people or not now in the
countries where we have our new platform
it's compulsory to use Markov power and
it doesn't have a cost for the seller
the cost is embedded in the Mercado
livre fee
but every seller has to offer Maricopa
because we believe it's a much better
experience for the buyer and our
objective is to have a hundred percent
of the transactions we're at twenty
percent currently or this was the
average for 2010 q4 was like closer to
thirty percent yes it's hard to test
what some of these things what we
typically do is we tried in a market and
we see what happens before we tried we
obviously look a lot at what's going on
around the world and if you look at the
most successful marketplaces which in my
opinion is iTunes and Amazon Marketplace
and more recently the Android
Marketplace in those marketplaces when
you buy you pay there isn't a difference
between buying and paying and in the
eBay marketplace and in our marketplace
still today there is a difference
between buying and paying you buy and
then you figure out with the seller how
you wish to pay and that creates a lot
of friction a lot of hassle it creates a
very high customer service cost for the
seller and for us so it was quite
obvious to us that this is a way to go
and we are we're going there but it
creates a lot of noise when you have a
big platform 4 million people selling on
it and you create a big change like this
it creates a lot of noise and you have
to be able to to maintain your decision
despite the noise eBay had a lot of
those problems some years ago when they
started to do some changes I think
Facebook is great at that they make
their minds about something they do it
and everybody complains and they say
this is this is going to be well if they
realize it's a mistake then they go back
but when you have an ecosystem with
millions of participants
you always hear lots of noise and you
have to be careful to separate the noise
between what is actually long-term best
for all the participants
okay so this is our payments platform
and very briefly mercado clics and
Mercado shops which are our two latest
launches mercado clics is basically an
adwords type of service were in in the
past we it was almost heresy to let
people go outside of our platform so we
wouldn't want anybody that was in
mercalli to leave our site and we with
the model we were very successful at
attracting small and medium sized
sellers to our platform but we were
never really successful at attracting
attracting and retaining large retailers
and large brands to our platform because
they didn't want to list on our platform
next to all these small and medium-sized
businesses that competed with them and
they also wanted to control the overall
buying experience
but through mercado clics we have been
able to build very good relationships
with very large retailers that are happy
to be on our platform and we also
believe we are offering a better buying
experience to the buyers that are now
able to see in one place the small and
medium size sellers and the ability also
to click away from there and buy in the
large retailer if they want to sometimes
they prefer to buy in large retailers
because of brad price guarantees brand
recognition or special offers that they
might have so it's a it has worked very
well for us we're obviously smaller than
Google in the region but we have we're
growing very rapidly and we have over
11,000 advertisers already so this is a
business that we believe has a huge
potential as well finally we launched
Mercado shops which is a web france web
store solution and it's also growing
extremely rapidly we launched it in the
second half of 2010 and we have already
over 5,000 web france web stores active
and this is basically the ability for
for anyone to do e-commerce online and
it comes integrated with Mercado power
and with Mercado Libre and with mercado
clics so it's very easy to generate
traffic to that store if you have some
inventory that you want to sell in Marco
because you're not selling it in your
platform it's very easy to transfer that
inventory to Mercalli and salad there
and vice versa and again it's the
installation of having this full
ecosystem where each one of the parts
helps the other and finally the some
financials for former cow Olivier in
2005 here we didn't dare go beyond 2005
so imagine what our revenues were our
first five years of operations not very
substantial but last year we had almost
220 million dollars of revenues and 56
million dollars of net income and
recently in our last earnings call we
announced our first dividend quarterly
dividend and the policies to payout 25
percent of the prior year's net income
to the shareholders so it's great - it's
a great feeling 11 years later to be
able to give back to our shareholders
some of the money that they have
invested so that concludes the
presentation and we can now open it up
to questions well we covered several of
those but for the first few years we
really try to recreate eBay but then we
saw that several things didn't work
first of all people preferred fixed
prices to auctions so we we move to
auctions very rapidly we've we've been
at 90% plus fixed prices for the last
eight nine years and eBay is still at
sixty percent roughly six fixed prices
going up because if they were three
years ago they were like at 40 percent
so I think I would say fixed prices is a
big one the recent change that we have
done with payments making Mercado Pago
compulsory to all the sellers and we're
moving forward to making it the usage
compulsory also to buyers I think is
going to be a big difference the way we
approached classifieds we quickly
realize that
you know people were not buying cars in
options even though they might or they
were doing it in in the u.s. we we
didn't think that was a right model so
we had completely we very rapidly did a
completely different business model for
for classifieds with different pricing
different Navigation different search
and it worked very well we are the
leaders in in motors in in every country
and and that's not the case for eBay in
Latin America sorry in the u.s. there
there are very strong vehicle sites here
in the US and then so I think those
those probably are the biggest tweaks
I'm sorry finally the free listings and
the the way we have been able to remain
very strong and I would say leaders in
classifieds here you have a Craigslist
which is very very big and very strong
you don't have anything nowhere near to
Craigslist in Latin America even though
free classifieds have existed there for
many years and I believe the reason is
that we captured that the c2c segment
better than then then what eBay did here
and more recently in a allowing free
classifieds free listings has been has
been a good part of that make was
actually here on Tuesday
decisions as CEO of eBay I was running
from your perspective for me what were
the pros and cons of receiving a
significant investment from eBay yeah I
was with Meg last night and she told me
she was here a few days ago so so it was
for us it was a very big win to partner
with eBay we had one with sign that they
would we knew it was going to be good we
weren't sure why so but we're willing to
do it almost at any price and we were
lucky that eBay didn't want to
consolidate our losses into their P&L so
they wanted to be under 20% of ownership
and so but you know we were willing to
do it I don't know not at any price but
we really wanted to do the deal we don't
know exactly why when we did it we
signed a best practice sharing agreement
and a non-compete agreement and the best
practice sharing which we didn't value
that much at the time ended up being
extremely valuable because coming to the
quarterly meetings at eBay and sharing
knowledge with them learning from their
the things they were doing right and the
things they were doing wrong was
incredibly advantageous for us and I
think it was also very helpful for them
because they saw in us we were we didn't
need their approval to do anything so we
would go and do things radically
different to them and they would they
would learn from that as well so I think
it was mutually convenient
obviously the consist I would have
preferred not to get diluted 20% but
they're surprised to everything
now obviously the partnership has
evolved a lot I mean when we signed it
it were almost like a subsidiary of eBay
and the non-competing competition
agreement expired five years ago it
lasted for five years from 2001 to 2006
and now we compete we compete with their
classifiers we compete with PayPal we
have a very good relationship with them
they're our largest minority shareholder
but they don't have a board seat and and
we have a we have a very good
relationship but we are also competitors
which is not unusual in our industry as
well I mean we are partners with Google
we're also competitors with Google and
Facebook and etc etc so
yeah I don't see those two things as
conflicting even though intuitively they
look very conflicting you say I have
this used mouse to sell how will anybody
see that Mouse if there are five
thousand you know Mouse is being sold by
by Best Buy or other large retailers but
it's it's interesting but it gets sold
anyhow if you if you have the right
price obviously c2c have a way for them
to gain market share within our
marketplace is to lower prices but the
way the internet works people don't
necessarily do a search and then go page
by page until they find the inventory
they they access inventory through
through natural search in Google or I
don't know but they get to the inventor
I don't know how they do it but they get
to the inventory and and and that 75 25
percent mix has been relatively stable
across the different countries so so
there is good liquidity in the c2c
marketplace as well even though free
listings are are the ones that you see
last one as a buyer when you do a search
this is well that is true how are you
turning every night you find your work
houses distant aspects of your business
that's a great question
we're not into logistics today and we
don't have plans to get into logistics
ourselves yet but that's something that
we are looking at closely and we'll see
what we need to do as as a market
evolves but currently what we're going
to be doing is partnering with the
people that do logistics in the region
and having them do logistics for us but
we plan to get involved much more
significantly in the shipping process
than what we are today today we are
we're letting the seller solve shipping
and each seller might have a different
solution there's an opportunity there to
get in the middle and negotiate better
prices on behalf of all of our sellers
and whenever there's a problem have our
selves interacting with the logistics
provider rather than the different
sellers so there's an opportunity to
improve what we're doing and that's what
we're going what we're going to be
working on in the next two years
basically with e-commerce there are two
very large friction points one is
payments and the other one is shipping
we believe payments were very close to
solving it with these things that I was
telling you that we're doing with
Mercado power and and shipping is the
next is the next big thing for us to
solve and we intend to solve it using a
similar approach to the one we have been
using in with payments
not to be yourself
in order to apply it which will only
partner with people who are already twin
logistics or you see the tweaks
well logistics in Latin America has many
issues particularly unions so so we are
happy not to do logistics and I think
it's going to be difficult to get into
logistics in Latin America when you add
the union's factor you logistics unions
are very powerful in some of the
countries so so we initially are not
intending to do it ourselves whether or
not it's feasible I don't know it's a
question for someone like Amazon
well I can tell you the ones we made we
we thought we were going to grow much
faster and then what we did per lead was
a consequence of the of the days when we
launched as I was saying before today
things have changed dramatically you see
companies like Groupon and Singh really
scaling very very very fast because the
Internet is much bigger and because many
of the bottlenecks like payments have
been solved already for them but we
thought we're going to scale much faster
we something I would do if I were to
start again is whenever you do a round
of financing secure more funding now
than what you think you might need in
case you don't grow as fast or you need
to spend more than what you thought and
then be very very careful the way you
spend the money I think one of the
things we did right relative to everyone
else in the region is we we really saved
the money for the rainy days and then
when the bubble burst and nobody was
able to access capital any longer and
the business yet wasn't there because
the internet was it was when we launched
it Internet penetration in the region
was 3% today is close to 40% so so
e-commerce which was a 10% of that 3%
was really very small so all our
competitors run out of cash and we still
had 40 million dollars in the bank so
that was important and I think the key
the most important thing for technology
startups is to focus on the product and
and get the product right and if there's
something that I regret is not having a
stronger technology background and
something that I think Stamford should
provide the GSB you graduate here
knowing accounting and you can you can
interact with an auditor and discuss a
P&L with them but you cannot interact
with a with a with a developer and
discuss the way they have written code
so and that that's a big handicap for
technology startups so if you don't have
that background as I did think it's
important to find a partner
the hats are very strong technology
background because that's the most
important thing the product yes justice
when you decide to start your company
how did you make it evolve of the
decision process of incorporating here
I'm staying in the Silicon Valley where
things here to be easier because of the
mentorship you can get from enterpreneur
the venture capital industry sphere as
opposed to as we think through the
decisions well it's it's so way you want
to live your life I mean that there's no
right or wrong there I just want you
know I was with my girlfriend we wanted
to go back to Argentina and so that's
why we decided to go back to business as
well so the barriers its time and its
product if you have a good product
people buy online and they don't see any
barriers now with a new payments
platform you come you come the second
time you buy online you do three clicks
and your credit card is stored there
your shipping address is stored there
and it's really easy you see buyer
protection and people feel very safe
doing it and we have a very high repeat
ratio of buyers that come and buy again
so so having a good product is helpful
and then it's time some people need some
time to they hear from their friends hey
I bought this on Marco Libre it's really
easy it's very you know simple and it's
a it's a function as Internet
penetration increases those barriers
come come down and with respect to the
data I think we could do a much
better job using our data we don't we
don't intend to monetize the data
selling into third parties or anything
like that but one of the big things
we're starting to look at is you know
doing the famous people who've seen this
have also bought that and people who
bought this have also bought that and
we're just in the very early days of
that but we're starting to do it to do
that well you need a you need to catalog
all that you structure all the data and
our our data was unstructured our
marketplace dead data so we've done a
very big effort in building our own
catalog of products trying to structure
that data so that we know that people
that bought exactly this mouth also
bought exactly this monitor and not just
any other monitor and once you have the
catalog then it's much easier to to do
those recommendations so I was saying
before I think we focus much more on
product less on PR and marketing they
were they were very good at that
we were probably not good at that so
that's why we focus more on product and
we we saved our money so and they spent
it all we I think overall we had a we
had a long-term vision of building a
company and that's probably what I would
encourage anyone who's starting think of
doing a start-up to have is really to
have a long-term vision of building a
company because then you have many many
difficulties along the way and if any of
your motivation is just to do an IPO or
have an exit or sell the company it's
it's not enough
sometimes you need a lot of patience
like we need it and and we had a long
term vision of building a company that
added value to millions of people I
think that that was very powerful
well we have a huge challenge because
the technology industry is is incredibly
competitive so whatever you did right in
the past is probably a weakness today
because you have a lot lots of legacy
and and we have lots of legacy if you
look at the players in the US there are
very few companies internet companies
that started in 1999 when we started
that are successful today and that's
because technology wise they have it's
been hard for them to adapt and we're in
the process of adapting we have we have
rewritten all of our code to have an
open platform with api's and to allow
enable third party to develop on top of
our platform that's something that we
didn't have we still it's still not live
today and that's going to be a major
major change so so basically
transforming our technologies is a big
challenge and if we do that well I think
we have tremendous tremendous potential
because I believe that growth in the
next years is going to be much faster
than the growth in the last year's so
with them kind of gone away from your
own to more of a distributed model what
are your thoughts on that in the future
I guess Commerce everywhere out there
the ladder commerce everywhere so if you
if you look at it mercado shops is that
but mercado clics and mercado pago the
open markup is also that so as what
while mercado libre continues to grow
very rapidly and it's our largest
business we believe it's going to it's
going to go towards the open model and
that's why we launched Mercado show up
somewhere district medical shops if you
will if you will
as a distributor of our payments
platform and our mercado clics our
traffic generation platform and also as
markali Rakosi
you can very easily transfer inventory
from one to the other so so market is
becoming more and more of an open
platform as well and with the API set
cetera
No the vision is to have let's say you
list an item on our platform
it's like listing a video on YouTube
then that item can appear as a video on
YouTube that it can appear anywhere in
any blog or in any you can see that item
anywhere and I'm by it so that's that's
a vision that we have from our career
and that's a part of transforming our
technology that we are doing opening it
up so that you can rather than going to
Mercalli wait to see this item or video
you can you can see it anywhere
you can embed that item anywhere and
actually buy it anywhere from a mobile
from phone from a tablet so I I see the
skill but the memory cornice is compared
to ebay are not that strong because
users between what are you raise those
are very physical very - there's very
little cross-border trade today payments
is a big part of solving that but it's
highly regulated and the people that are
doing it are not public companies that
need to comply with all the laws like we
do it's it's very very complex to
transfer money from Argentina to Peru or
from Argentina to Chile without having
many licenses in the region so and then
obviously there's duties and customs so
that's not our focus our focus is the
mark the e-commerce that happens within
each one of the countries and we believe
it's a huge market for that
but I would let you know about how you
started actually I mean did you find a
technical co-founder and you said before
you need to be you need someone your
team so we yes my cousin has a technical
background and he started the company
with me and we interesting fun story we
started we bought an auction software
from a company that was called open site
it was eventually bought by by a larger
player I can't remember now by whom they
were in North Carolina I believe and
digest in North Carolina and we bought
it for $15,000 it was a terrible
technology but it enabled us to launch
we knew we're going to have lots of
competition and on the mean time we had
some developers doing our own platform
so so but but initially we bought on an
off-the-shelf software which we
installed in the servers and when we
started with that I was wondering why
you have not penetrated the few
countries that we see in
partly it's because the technology that
we have that we're changing it's costly
for us to do each each country each new
country is costly so typically to add
one feature in Brazil has a better
payoff than launching in Bolivia but
that's the reason why we are completely
overhauling our technologies what we are
able to launch in many more countries
and move much more rapidly than what we
have been doing in the past you move
really faster there wasn't some sense of
urgency when you create a business they
want to know if you work you today as a
student then you need to run as fast as
you can or you can wait for I mean if
you're going to be in the technology
industry you need to run faster and what
you can that's why you need a great team
and basically it's very very stressful
and it doesn't stop it's always like
that so I think you haven't asked
but his company you bought was here in
the States
for you lose everything or they miss a
permit so this probably does only does
one of people right now like very
complicated process here so what do you
feel about
if you serve the last 10 years
most of the largest companies in Brazil
and in Latin America
our local versions of companies in India
a secular cattle evil to my in Brazil
how do you see in the next 10 years it's
a better investment for China to
regulate proven business models here
there or is like investing new models I
don't know it's a hard question to
answer
but what I would say is it's very hard
to replicate a business model in the
region because you cannot replicate it
you need to adapt it it's always there
are many differences and so
yeah oh there are many obviously the
group buying stuff is extremely hot and
it's working very well over there as
well games on the internet we we do
payments for some game gaming companies
in the region and they are growing very
very fast
the biggest platform is Orkut in Brazil
but Facebook is growing very very fast
in the region and in Brazil so so those
those are I see people doing very well
in those spaces and yeah
European platform benefits from the fact
they have cattle we pray for that same
time
it's tough it's very tough to build it
because you need to create scale and
it's very difficult to reach scale so I
think that it's easier for for Google
Checkout now with Android for example
and Facebook with Facebook Credits but
they don't use real money they are just
using facebook credit so in a way they
are complementary but I don't know I
don't know I think I think there might
be more than one but probably the
largest will have a substantial share of
of the you know value created if you
will so probably there's going to be
more than one if you look at the credit
cards industry that's probably similar
to what will happen online within the
technology technology center man but
maybe even beyond the technology center
what are the the proneural trends that
you see in like if you use Marcus in
Latin America like what are they working
on and also like do you think I feel a
lot more entrepreneurship in the region
endeavor this foundation that that
selected us in 1999 has been doing an
amazing job in the region through
universities and working with
governments and everyone is very aware
of how valuable it is to have
intrapreneurs in our country because
they generate mobile progress you know
mobility to within a society and
innovation and jobs and so so there's a
very big focus on entrepreneurship in
all the countries and and I see many
many many people doing doing stuff so I
think the environment is very good and
there's venture capitalists obviously
it's not Silicon Valley but it's a big
change from what it was 11 years ago
so I think what we wanted to do is do
enough advertising to make sure that we
were going to be amongst the survivors
but do as little as we could to save as
much money as possible because we we
knew that we were just throwing money
out the window because it was like
saying you know advertising something
that then when people go to a
supermarket it it's not there it's not
displayed there so if Internet
penetration was 3% on TV you you target
a hundred percent of the population so
right away you're spent wasting ninety
seven percent of the money so we did
very little TV but we did enough so that
because interestingly enough the venture
capitalists and all the financial
community were the ones that were asking
and pushing for people to spend money so
we were like okay well we have to do
something because otherwise they won't
invest in our round of financing because
they think we won't survive but we know
that this is another way to go so no I
would definitely save that money it was
a waste of money okay we have what time
for one more question if there is
otherwise thank you
you